Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to why don't
we try Ruth from Canada.
Ruth, you are on the air.
Speaker 7: And David,
Speaker 1: where in Canada are you calling
from, Alberta.
Oh, beautiful.
That's a very conservative area, isn't it?
Speaker 7: Oh, yes, unfortunately.
Speaker 1: What's what's going on now?
Speaker 7: So I have to question, a few years
ago, I think you hosted or you produced a
bunch of YouTube clips about discussing logical
policies and things like that.
I'm wondering if you would do an updated version
of that?
Speaker 1: Well, you know, Ruan, I don't know
if we're going to update that specifically,
but we are now working.
This is exclusive to Ruth from Canada announcement.
We are now looking at revitalizing our sort
of long form deep dives and really competing
head on with the trash from Prager U.
And they're bogus right wing explainers.
So this is currently in development.
And so I don't know if we're going to redo
the critical thinking series, but we're going
to do all sorts of new explainers.
And I think that there will be a lot of things
to look forward to as far as that goes.
Speaker 7: For looking forward to it, my second
question is McConnells just confirmed and
no surprise to anyone that he wouldn't support
an independent investigation of the January
6th riot.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and the term independent,
I mean, it's really what we're talking about
is bipartisan, right?
Democrats.
It's not so much independent as bipartisan,
but, yeah, Mitch McConnell said he's not going
to support it.
Speaker 7: Well, what do you think the likely
what do you think the likelihood is that the
investigation will be able to move forward?
Speaker 1: I actually think it will, partially
because it's the House that would be doing
it.
And Mitch McConnell is in the Senate.
I know he still wields power, of course, but
there are also at least 20 and maybe as many
as 50 Republicans who want to see it happen.
So I think that I do believe it will happen.
Speaker 7: OK, well, let me show.
Thanks so
Speaker 1: much.
Thanks, Ruth.
Great to hear from you.
Sorry you're in such a right wing haven in
in in Canada.
There I've heard a lot of things about Alberta
can get pretty brutal from what I've read.
OK, we're speaking to people via discord.
David Pakman Dotcom's discord is the place
to find it.
Let's go next to Sam from New York City.
You're on the air.
Speaker 5: Thanks so much for taking my call.
I just wanted to ask, you know, I'm all about
abolishing the filibuster.
I'm all about putting pressure on Joe Manchin
and the like.
I think that is critical if we want to get
aggressive agenda passed, especially some
of these voting like bills.
But, you know, Virginia, I think it's like
the second Trumpy state in terms of just like,
you know, 20, 20 share.
And so my concern is that even though I don't
agree with the more moderate Democrats, I
think being too willing to criticize an outsider
within the party could just result in a future
where you get 50 votes.
In the Senate, we're looking at six forty
seven.
Forty eight, as we sort of, if any, chance
of having Democratic senators in purple or
redder states goodbye.
You know.
Speaker 1: I totally agree with you.
I've been making this point for years, and
I know that there are people who will get
mad at this example.
But here's the reality.
If you primary Joe Manchin with Bernie Sanders
and Democrats in West Virginia, pick Bernie
over Joe Manchin, I don't see how the hell
Bernie then wins the general Senate election
in West Virginia.
Now, maybe at some point that specific example
won't be a good one.
But I completely agree with you in principle,
which is sometimes when when Democrats want
to replace a centrist Democrat with a further
left Democrat, the most likely scenario would
be that it's just a Republican who wins, and
that's worse.
Speaker 5: No, exactly, I completely agree,
and I guess I disagree in terms of getting
rid of the filibuster, though, I support it.
If you do that in isolation, that's what really
concerns me, because in isolation, you eliminate
the filibuster.
But we're in a system.
What if the Republicans got 40 million Democrats,
that 40 million more votes in the most recent
Senate elections than Republicans, yet the
Senate will split when there's such a structural
disadvantage for Democrats?
I think creating a moral majority and system,
the Senate, when the Senate is so biased towards
Republicans could be a recipe for disaster.
Republicans seem to support any real policy
anyway.
Speaker 1: I completely agree with you.
And the other important thing to remember
is there are you know, when we talk about
the obstacles to getting X done, rarely is
there one blanket explanation for why X won't
get done.
There's usually different explanations for
different things when you have a bill that
Joe Biden wants, but two Democratic senators
don't want versus a bill that Joe Biden wants.
But every senator wants but every Democratic
senator wants, but it requires 60 instead
of 50, meaning it's now on Republicans.
Every one of these scenarios is a different
scenario.
And there's not one solution and the solution
of just primary every centrist Democrat, and
then it'll solve all your problems.
I don't think it's a realistic solution.
I think it will maybe solve some and create
new problems as well.
Speaker 5: Would you mind if I ask one last
question?
Speaker 1: Go ahead, by the way, is this Sam
Ceder or a different Sam from New York City?
Speaker 5: Different.
Different.
OK, got it.
OK, I'm calling actually.
Got it.
Yeah, what I was going to say is I was just
wondering your take one thing that really
frustrates me is how American centric American
world views and political views tend to be,
and just that all of our focus is always on
domestic politics.
There are only like huge British elections
that are this week and the crises happening
across the globe.
And I understand that a lot is happening in
the US and it's good to pay attention.
But what do you think is our responsibility
as Americans to have the privilege to have
access to global news, to stay up to date
on not only international politics, but the
domestic politics of other countries?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I think that I would
prioritize if you if you find someone who
pays no attention to what's going on outside
the U.S., I would suggest first start paying
attention to what's going on internationally.
That would be a higher priority than knowing
the internal politics of other countries.
If you if you say, well, pick one to start
with.
I think it's very easy when you live in a
country like the United States that dictates
so much of global culture and global technology
and so many different things just to basically
be in an island and only pay attention to
what happens in the U.S.. I think it leads
to very narrow world views, and I think it
leads to people who it leads to that wing
of the Republican Party where we said, hey,
earlier this week, Europe announced it would
open to vaccinated people.
And I said, you know, I don't think this will
be much of an incentive to the anti vaccine
Republicans because they already think Europe
is just about sissies and communists.
There's a whole culture of people who proactively
are hostile to the idea of what happens in
other countries mattering.
And you have to change the culture around
that.
Speaker 5: Totally, I think when you consider
just how crucial the role of our allies is
and you look at the fact that, right, Germany
is going to have a new chancellor at the end
of the year, France has elections next summer,
a lot of things are going to change, even
a lot of things that could impact Joe Biden's
ability to get his foreign policy agenda done.
Yeah, we paid a little attention, but I agree
with you about the prioritization.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend, thank you
for the call.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 5: Because so much here.
Speaker 1: All right, you two of really strong
calls today, I have to tell you a lot of very
interesting topics.
Why don't we go next to let's just try somewhere
else.
Let's go to Alfie in London now.
Is that London, UK?
Speaker 5: Yeah, yeah, London, UK,
Speaker 1: well, welcome, you're on the air.
Speaker 5: Hey, thanks for picking me up.
I just thought would it be okay if I just
use you as a way to settle a long time dispute?
Speaker 1: I can try.
Sure, I can try.
Speaker 5: So would you say a flamingo is
pink, or would you say peach is probably a
better way to describe it?
Speaker 1: You know, I think that flamingos
I would describe them as salmon colored.
Speaker 5: Oh, no.
Yeah, I oh, that's just made it worse, OK?
Speaker 1: I mean, I think it's more I you
know, I think it actually depends on it.
Now I know that there's people who will say
the flamingo is white, but it takes on the
color of of what it eats.
We're dealing with what color does it end
up right.
I think that's really the question that you're
asking.
I think it's regionally different, to be perfectly
honest.
I think in some cases it's more pink, in some
cases is more peach.
Speaker 5: OK, yeah, OK.
Oh, that doesn't help David.
Speaker 1: I'm sorry.
Speaker 5: All right, you're voting third
party right now by choosing someone, I hope
you know that I'm sorry.
Speaker 1: I'm doing what so?
Oh, by Sam and I'm third party.
Yes.
Listen, how are things in London?
You guys are doing so well with cases and
deaths being so low?
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think that may be the calm
before the storm.
Oh, really?
Everyone's the Indian variant at the moment.
Speaker 1: The Indian variant is well handled
by the vaccines from everything I've read.
Speaker 5: Yeah, yeah, but it's just of the
talk of the town at the moment, I see.
But yeah, as of Monday, we're able to eat
in those groups of up to six people.
Yep.
Yeah, it's looking good.
Speaker 1: What is your you know, one of the
things I love about the UK in general is all
of the different pubs with different names
that are often very similar, but just slightly
different, like, you know, the lamb's head
and the, you know, all these different things.
What is the name of your favorite pub?
Speaker 5: Um, oh, I think.
Do you mean do you mean my favorite name of
a pub or the name of my favorite
Speaker 1: pub, I will accept either, but
ideally one that you like going to.
Speaker 5: There is a really nice place in
London called the The Green Pea, love it yourself.
Yeah, and it's really nice.
Yeah, I'm not sure how they're doing at the
moment because the owner, it was owned and
operated by this one guy who passed away about
a year back.
Speaker 1: I'm sorry to hear that.
Speaker 5: No.
Yeah, but it was a really nice place, local
for us, and so we went to that all the time
Speaker 1: and they do they do Sunday roast
and everything.
Speaker 5: Yeah, yeah.
Speaker 1: They got to love that Sunday roast,
you know.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I'm not the biggest fan mean,
there's a bit of sacrilegious.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, I don't like it, you
know.
Speaker 5: Well, you just said you love it.
Speaker 1: All right.
No, I'm just kidding around.
I do actually like it.
Last time I was there, I went to a great Sunday
roast.
They had a vegan option, a vegetarian option,
a meat eaters option.
They had a pasta, as you say.
They had everything honest.
Yeah.
All right.
Thank you for the call.
I really appreciate it.
Speaker 5: Yep.
Thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right.
Perfect, perfect call.